[Musique]
ce mardi 28 juin éco village a ouvert
ses portes sur le campus de l'université
de la réunion moufia qui fête ses 40 ans
d'existence
stand d'écomobilité de revalorisation
des déchets de sensibilisation au
développement durable étaient proposés
aux personnels et étudiants de
l'établissement alors c'est une journée
qui est importante puisque c'est une
journée de transition c'est un premier
pas qu'on a posé vers un éco campus
démonstratif exemplaire en matière de
développement durable et responsabilité
sociétale c'est aussi le partenariat
avec le conseil départemental qui va
nous permettre de végétaliser l'ensemble
de nos campus pour entrer en sol
américain en effet les deux institutions
ont signé un partenariat impliquant la
mise à disposition de 25 mille arbres
destinés à revégétaliser les campus
universitaires au travers du plan un
million d'arbres pour la réunion porté
par la collectivité aujourd'hui c'est un
acte essentiel et fondateur que nous
passons aux vacuum l'université de la
réunion et son président frédéric
miranville tout simplement parce que
l'université on le sait forme
l'excellence
de notre jeunesse donc nous amène à une
jeunesse formée qualifiés et quand on
veut planter des arbres à la réunion
bien évidemment on ne peut pas passer à
côté de l'idée que l'université doit
être partenaire parce que il s'agit pour
nous de mettre des plantes bien sûr
entière mais il faut aussi développer
nos connaissances de notre écosystème et
la l'université est un partenaire
incontestable un nouvel espace
revégétaliser a été inauguré à cette
occasion
[Musique]